in this video I want to introduce  glycogen storage diseases or GSD s which  are also called  glycogen OCS so what are they they are  autosomal recessive disorders that are  the specifically enzyme deficiencies  that result in an increased amount of  stored glycogen which is either going to  be due to an increase in glycogen  synthesis or a decrease in glycogen  breakdown right there will be more  stored glycogen either we're making more  of it or we're now breaking down enough  of it okay or we've got structurally  abnormal stored glycogen that would be  due to a decrease in either of the the  enzymes involving with branching or d  branching right so what I've got here is  a little table that I'm a summary  you